I feel like anybody I talk to who does
this kind of job is anxious and if
they're not they're sociopaths
top of the morning dear ladies
[Music]
I'm Sean McLaughlin I go by
jacksepticeye online and I make YouTube
videos and it's kind of a mixed bag I
started off playing video games on my
channel and just reacting to those and
it blew up out of nowhere and then I
just kind of branched off and now I do
everything I just react to content I do
games I do sketch comedy I made short
films I've done interactive media so
for now it's kind of like whatever's
creative whatever's fun I don't really
tie myself to one genre anymore yeah I
started kind of very very end of 2012.
my plan initially was to do imitations
or like impersonations and then do
content around that and kind of be that
character and then I did it once and was
like this is terrible I shouldn't upload
this so I was just watching a lot of
people who would play games and kind of
react to them and have fun that way and
I I thought that was really cool I just
tried it out for myself to see if it
would work and I I really like the sort
of editing process and kind of curating
it and getting in okay what's my idea
What's My Line to go through and
obviously it's all pretty bad when you
start off but it was kind of fun to have
a project to do every day and I was kind
of aimless in my life at that time so I
was like I need I need something to kind
of like attach myself to as I got better
at it more people started watching a
kind of snowballed really quickly and
then I don't know I was kind of in it
before I realized I was in it I didn't
really have any time to think about it
or overthink
March me I kind of said to myself right
I'll hit 1 000 subscribers before I go
back to college in September and it's
it's mid-july right now and we already
hit that goal is it 2 000 subscribers on
YouTube you believe it we
two weeks after hitting six hundred
thousand the channel is now at 700 000
subscribers congrats on getting the
channel to 3 million subscribers as of
right now the channel stands at 4
million people strong thank you guys so
much for 11 million subscribers here is
the one trick that I used to get 25
million subscribers on YouTube and you
can do it too all right are you
listening get closer
I have no idea I was in college at the
time and when I finally started making
like a decent living off of it I started
to earn enough to like pay rent and pay
for amenities every month and I I was
able to like rent a place on my own I
really started to be like oh God this is
like my job now I don't actually have to
find work and actually do this full time
and I think that that was the big moment
where I was like okay I don't know how
long this will last it could all fall
apart in the morning because it's so
volatile it can go either way and
especially at those lower numbers I
didn't really know what was going to
happen
I think people think it's easy that
because if you sit down and you play
games but I think there's so much more
to it because when I started off I'm
like I edit I Photoshop I record all
this stuff I do it multiple times a day
I did it five and a half years without
skipping a b twice every single day at
the exact same time and I think that
sheer amount of effort that goes into it
like it is really really hard work but
also comes the emotional side of it
which is a lot of anxiety and a lot of
stress and trying not you're like
there's no training for it you kind of
you're you're your own brand if it grows
quick and big like mine did you kind of
have to navigate that yourself and hope
that you're dealing with it properly and
early on I wasn't because there was a
lot of like
like stuff that I had to work out about
burnout and try not to overwork myself
and there's no there's no one telling
like telling you like to pull yourself
back a little bit I've always been quite
a social person I I like hanging out
with people and I like talking with
friends and playing games together and I
think when I was growing up in Ireland
there wasn't a whole lot of people that
thought the same way I did and didn't
play games the same way I did and I
thought it was some sort of a weirdo
that like why am I playing games for so
much time so when I was online there was
more people that did that and when you
meet other YouTubers they're doing the
same job they all kind of get you and
there's like an unspoken bond between
you kind of like yeah say your truth I
get you
I would love to be that guy I'd love to
be like I wake up 6 a.m every morning I
meditate I get my coffee in I drink my
top of the morning and I just I comb my
hair a thousand times and I just read my
Mantra to myself and then write down all
my ideas and every one of them is great
so I have to just pick but I'm not I'm
just like
I don't know I didn't sleep well my back
hurts and then I just roll into it it's
surprising that it's worked for as long
as it has because I keep waiting for it
to not work but people still watch and I
I have that like imposter syndrome where
I'm like they're gonna find out
eventually that I don't know what I'm
doing
I'm in a fortunate position where if I
if I attempt to do anything I already
have a built-in audience for it which is
what most new companies are trying to
get is how do we spread this to as many
people as possible and I'm just lucky
enough I have a platform I I try not to
take on the things that I'm not really
excited about and I think if I have a
passion for it and I'm excited about it
and I really want to do it I think that
shows a lot and people kind of follow
along in the journey and it's kind of
fun for them and I think that's what
people
react to because they can tell that it's
kind of coming from a good decent place
and you're not trying to just pull the
wall over the rise and kind of like sell
a product to them but it's finally time
to announce cloak which is a clothing
company and a clothing brand that
America and I have come together to try
and create me and my friend Mark or
Markiplier as he's known on the internet
we we came up with that idea together to
because we've done merch before and kind
of like put our faces on stuff but we're
like What would it be like if we went
that extra step further and we kind of
created something that had its own
identity and and I think both of us kind
of have a an interesting clothing and
fashion and uh that sort of world and
how can like we put our spin on it how
can we add our voice to it and kind of
like make it fun and it was just it was
something really creative and fun to do
and I think both of our strengths kind
of play to that aspect when we kind of
get in a room together and we bash out
ideas together we've done some cool fun
stuff with it and people have responded
really well to it and the clothing is
really high quality and we try and make
it actually like really decent stuff for
people to be able to get I personally
never want to do that thing where I'm
just kind of like selling something and
then never think about it again and I
think Mark is the same way where
we're both sort of proud to put our
names on it and kind of work on stuff
together and especially with YouTubers
starting Brands there's a sort of
misconception about it sometimes and I
we legitimately just wanted to make
really really good coffee that you could
drink day after day
thank you
[Music]
I made my own coffee company my own
coffee brand and it is called top of the
morning coffee I was just sitting down I
was like I like coffee so much and I'm
like yeah can I make a coffee brand I
was like I don't know if I can like is
that something that I'm even able to do
do we know people that can make that
happen and then I thought of the name
top of the morning coffee and I was like
oh now we have to do it that name's way
too good not to do and the the more we
did it the more I was like oh we we
could do something actually really cool
with this and have fun with it and it
was the the more I got into it and
understood how everything worked the
more potential I saw in it and I thought
it was really cool so then I just kind
of ran with it and I was like if this
fails it'll be at least it's like a cool
thing to kind of experience and get into
but
um we tried really hard to make it like
a cool identifiable brand and got really
into it but I think the more we did it
we started to realize like there's not
much of my personality in The Branding
and I'm I'm quite like an energetic
Lively person and try and be positive
about a lot of things so we rebranded it
we kind of looked at it and stood back
and we're like okay it kind of looks
like other coffee brands we wanted to
stand out on its own and that's why we
came up with like the yellow bags and
the new logo to kind of like be a bit
punchier and our mascots like a sun
characters we're like What if the bag
looks like a ray of sun sitting on your
shelf and the more we talked about it uh
we sat down with an agency and they kind
of like asked me a whole bunch of
questions and they were like oh so
you're you're all about this
and it was all about like absurd
positivity and I think they captured
that quite well I I don't pretend to be
like a business Mogul where I'm going
out and trying to be like a billionaire
or anything like that
um I just try and make fun things that
people can react to and kind of have
like an emotional attachment to as well
instead of it just being like yeah I buy
it because it tastes good like it's so
much more than that it's kind of like an
experience and a lifestyle for people at
this point
[Music]
tons of ideas I want to like
like make comic books I want to do
narrative podcasts I have like movie
ideas I have TV show ideas I want to do
more voice acting I want to do more like
Mainline acting because I'm in a very
fortunate position that I get to like
put my fingers in a lot of pies I get to
try out a lot of different things that a
lot of people can't so I don't want to
take that for granted and I want to take
advantage of it wherever I can I think
anybody that wants to be a Creator
should try
um it certainly afforded me a lot of
great things in my life and I all the
people I know and the person that I am
today is all because of that kind of
stuff so I'm not going to say don't try
it I think it's really cool there's not
one way of doing it there's a million
different ways to do it and people are
really clever and really funny and I
think if they get to show the world that
in a short form or a long form or on
Instagram on Twitter wherever you want
to do it I think that's cool
thank you